1,2 millions c'est le nombre de trajets
réalisés par les trottinettes
électriques tirent depuis leur lancement
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines en mai 2021
grâce à une application mobile il est
possible de réserver facilement son
véhicule 24 heures sur 24 un nouveau
moyen de transport qui a séduit plus de
65000 clients dans l'agglomération une
de 75% des utilisateurs aujourd'hui ce
sont des hommes donc on travaille aussi
avec l'opérateur à essayer de
rééquilibrer la tendance jeune jeune
c'est-à-dire entre 16 ans et un peu plus
de la trentaine plus de 1000
trottinettes principalement utilisées
pour des trajets domiciles travaillent
en intermodalité avec les gars SNCF de
l'agglomération la crise des carburants
de ces dernières semaines a permis une
augmentation du service de 20%. c'est un
territoire stratégique puisque nous
sommes en zone périurbaine ou encore 70%
des déplacements sont faites sont faits
en voiture individuelle il y a un vrai
intérêt à proposer des solutions comme
celle-ci qui sont flexibles pratiques en
libre-service
tout le temps pour aller en cours ou
sinon pour aller chercher mes courses
parce que ça va plus vite les
trottinettes ont une vitesse bridée à 20
km/h et parfois à 10 km/h dans les eaux
les plus fréquentées cet accident ont
été relevés depuis l'ouverture du
service pour éviter une amende de 25 €
les clients doivent restituer leur
trottinette dans l'une des 300 stations
ces pénalités n'empêche pas la présence
de certains véhicules égarés le long des
routes cette utilisateur reproche le
manque de liberté causé par ce
dispositif moi ce matin ma trottinette
personnelle elle a crevée donc j'en ai
j'ai pris une tière pour aller au
travail mais il y a pas de spot juste à
côté
où on peut les on peut les laisser les
tiers et donc j'ai dû j'ai dû marcher un
peu quoi jusqu'au boulot mais bon fort
de son succès sur l'agglomération 56 la
société tir mobility a récemment élargi
la zone d'utilisation les trottinettes
ont été déployées à Saint-Cyr-l'École
Bois-d'Arcy et Buc désormais 40 communes
des Yvelines utilisent ce service